Film Courage: Keith, do you come from a line
of filmmakers?
Keith Sutliff: No.
No, I don’t.
I’m the first one actually (in my family).
Film Courage: Okay.
So I just find it fascinating that you had
sort of this business vision along with a
creative vision to go to AFM [American Film
Market] with a script that was not finished
yet?
Keith Sutliff: Correct.
Film Courage: And already trying to find distribution
for it.
That’s pretty amazing.
Where are you getting that…those ideas from?
Keith Sutliff: You know…American Film Market
is usually in November of every year in Santa
Monica, California.
And when I went there I was in the process
of writing THE MASON BROTHERS and I had two
other projects with finished scripts that
I was trying to get off the ground.
However, one of my good buddies in the business
(also a director and a producer).
He recommended to me prior to that (a couple
of years ago)…he’s like “Hey, you have
to go to the American Film Market.
This is the place you have to go for meeting
distributors and it’s just great networking.
You’ve just got to go.”
He was just telling me how it worked and stuff.
He kind of mentored me and gave me advice
on how the whole process worked, and walking
to the different hotel room suites and meet
with the distributors and stuff.
He kind of pitched the idea to me.
This is a business, that’s what it is.
It is creative, but in my opinion it is more
business that it is creativity in a sense.
I mean it is creative but it’s business
is what it is.
So you make a film (especially a feature film)
your goal should be obviously you want to
make a product.
You do what you love and you’re passionate
about it but also try to make some profit
off of it, if you can.
It’s just smart to go some place like a
like the American Film Market or some other
market to try and sell a film or anything
you have from your production company, or
other projects which you are trying to get
started.
So it’s just wise to do that.
I was just thinking with a business mind that’s
what should be done and my friend was telling
me to do that, so I did it.
Film Courage: Do you see other filmmakers
around you, maybe the ones you went to film
school with or people that you’ve talked
to here in Los Angeles that have that same
mindset?
Because some people get very offended thinking
that their work of art is also a product?
And I can see how it would make people mad,
but in actuality it’s true, it’s a product.
Keith Sutliff: Right, that’s just what it
is.
Some people have that same mindset but some
people don’t but they have a lot of their
own agenda of how they want to do things.
Most filmmakers that I’ve met, a majority
go to film festivals to try to get distribution
for their films or just some type of exposure.
Yes, a lot of people have that mindset but
maybe some more than others.
Some people treat [filmmaking] as more of
a business and some don’t.
Some hustle harder and trying to get their
film distributed or some kind of pre-sales
deal prior to shooting it.
It really just depends on the individual.
I’ve seen seen different people do it different
ways.
But me, I think American Film Market and going
there to get some type of distribution deal
prior is important.